[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrados
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana hablamos de un
tema social muy polémico muy espinoso un
auténtico tabú social y que en francia
está de plena actualidad por un libro y
una campaña que se ha desatado por un
caso muy conocido hablamos del incesto y
para me acompañan en este estudio tres
invitados que ya les pasó a presentar
silvia yus o corresponsal del país en
francia bienvenida silvia
leonardo martinelli corresponsal del
diario tele no la stampa que en francia
bienvenido a leonardo ahora en nuestra
compañía también maría eugenia rival
blue uriburu es psicóloga especialista
en psico traumas y terapias de
orientación psicoanalítica bienvenida a
mario genia punto el tabú social del
incesto hoy en primera plana
de francia se ha abierto la caja de
pandora de un tema que hasta ahora
suscitaba bastante tabú el incesto la
chispa ha sido un libro publicado por la
jurista camil kirchner hija del ex
ministro francés bernard kouchner en el
que narra los abusos sexuales que sufrió
su hermano gemelo por parte de su
padrastro el célebre politólogo francés
olivier duhamel miembro de la élite
intelectual parisina todo un escándalo
que ha desatado una campaña en redes
sociales llamada mito incesto en el que
miles de personas están atreviéndose a
denunciar los abusos que sufrieron en el
pasado tal repercusión está teniendo el
asunto en francia- que incluso el
presidente macrón se ha comprometido a
hacer frente a este tabú que según
algunas estimaciones atención no es nada
minoritario en la sociedad hasta un 10
por ciento de los franceses han podido
sufrir este tipo de violencia repasemos
algunas portadas antes de ir con el tema
la revista lux el fin de un tabú con el
testimonio de camille kirchner ese caso
al que nos referíamos ya no podía
callarme dice la autora del libro que ha
supuesto todo este revuelo en francia
incesto un combate contra el silencio y
explica el diario lo complicado que
tiene la justicia llegar muchas veces
a dar con las evidencias de este crimen
tan silencioso y doloroso varios medios
de la prensa francesa recogen estos días
testimonios muy duros de incesto lo hace
también el diario libération el castigo
infligido a un niño es inimaginable pero
de repente un caso silvia conocido
enciende una chispa y nos damos cuenta
que el incesto no era tan residual y tan
marginal como nos pensábamos no no lo es
no les en francia- y no lo es en muchas
partes del mundo excepto las ese 10% en
francia según una encuesta que se hizo
en diciembre para alguna asociación que
lucha precisamente contra el incesto
pero cifras similares se manejan en
otros muchos países de europa además es
un problema que siempre citan los
expertos por ejemplo says the children
en españa' que también ha intentado
indagar sobre este tema es que no hay
estadísticas judiciales precisamente por
lo que hablamos ese tabú que es hasta
ahora es un problema los abusos sexuales
contra menores siempre son un problema
lo hemos visto también
y recientemente con todos los casos de
la iglesia que está investigando este
problema muy grande que tiene también lo
vimos el año pasado con la salida de
otro libro mucho pero con una onda de
choque muy fuerte en francia el
consentimiento de vanessa spring ahora
donde también contaba la relación que
ella mantuvo a los 14 años con un
escritor de casi 50 gabriel masner que
empezó a remover esto esta es la primera
puerta que se abrió fuerte para hablar
del tema de abusos sexuales contra
menores pero es un tema que como bien
dice es cómo demostrar a la campaña mi
tu incesto afecta a todas las capas
sociales y como es un problema que
además es rompe familias como estamos
viendo en otros casos que están saliendo
a raíz del libro de camille kirchner
ahora está en francia en la acusación de
la hija del actor richard berry contra
su padre también la acusa de haber
mantenido relaciones incestuosas con
ella que es un no hay testigos más que
dentro de la familia rompe familias
el silencio empieza muchas veces en la
familia ese es el gran problema de este
caso que van más por supuesto el trauma
maria eugenia es la experta en ello
que que impone un silencio en la familia
leonardo le ha sorprendido más allá del
caso en particular la magnitud que está
que está teniendo toda esta campaña de
mitú incesto en francia a partir de este
caso me sorprendió la magnitud también
el hecho que estas historias se pasan en
familias de nivel cultural alto muchas
veces en estos círculos decimos de la
gauche caviar como se llama en parís
círculos intelectuales de hicieron a la
progresía intelectual declaró esto
exista así esto creo que es creo que él
por mala suerte el fenómeno de la del
incesto es un fenómeno que hay en otros
países en mi país en italia también
pero quizás que acá hay un elemento
particular es que en los años 70 los
años 80 este círculo de la izquierda
de la gente intelectual que fue el
producto también del 68 legítimo este
tipo
el incesto pero la pedofilia y esto ya
fue fue muy grave y esto también sería
un discurso a la amplió porque en
francés se utiliza esto para decir que
el 68 fue negativo que es un dominio que
yo no comparto para nada pero de este
punto de vista así porque esta sed de
libertad que fue el producto el fruto de
la del 68 llegó también a ésta a algunas
de generaciones como en el caso de la
pedofilia y puedo recordar una cosa que
él el padre de caminera bernard kouchner
que con supuesto apoyo a su hija y
condenó este acto firmó a la ftc en 1977
una petición que firmaron muchos otros
otras muchas otras personas una petición
para apoyar 3
pedófilos que estaban en frente al
juicio en un tribunal de parís entonces
eso no es para contar bernard kouchner
va para decir que había un contacto muy
particular en francia quizá para usted
señora uriburu esa magnitud de esta
magnitud social y mediática que a lo
mejor a nosotros como periodistas nos
sorprende mucho a usted le sorprende
menos porque es conocedora de esta
realidad del incesto sorprende en parte
porque en la magnitud social que es
tiene efectos expansivos en muchas de
las personas que son que han sido
víctimas de este tipo de actos tiene
efectos positivos porque libera la
palabra pero también negativos en el
sentido que revive a las personas que
han vivido este tipo de actos
estar confrontado de nuevo a una
reminiscencia bueno tienen consecuencias
físicas importantes pero pero por
supuesto que es positivo que la palabra
se libere y sorprende pero bueno porque
la palabra se libera el va totalmente
enlazado al elemento troncal del incesto
que es el silencio no es el elemento
sobre el que se articula todo
exactamente el silencio la culpa
y gracias a esto se permite
que este tipo de violencias continuó en
el tiempo y se tienen este elemento tan
destructor el silencio la imposibilidad
de hablar de calificar el hecho si
igualmente a dentro de la de la familia
o por fuera hablar con otros etcétera el
libro este es muy interesante justamente
porque explica como ella vive el
silencio el peso del silencio y la iv
como una especie de monstruo que lava a
ella que no fue la que fue directamente
yo lava como es el caso de su hermano
porque la apelación no olvidemos este
son violaciones forzada este pero bueno
el silencio tiene tiene este efecto
devastador nos referíamos antes a ese
libro lo explica yo más o menos en la
introducción la grande familia usted ha
escrito sobre sobre el tema silvia se
refería es a ese título del libro al
círculo intelectual precisamente que
antes comentaba el círculo intelectual
que sé
en que se movía olivier dominó y oliver
de vélez es un politólogo un
constitucionalista muy conocido en
francia hasta hace nada era uno de los
decidores de la élite intelectual y de
los formadores porque tenía tenía un
puesto muy grande responsabilidad de
pensiones porque es uno de los viveros
de las élites intelectuales culturales
políticas periodísticas de francia su
mujer que es la madre de camille y de su
hermano que tiene usa un usa un nombre
ficticio víctor en el libro es el impi
sie que era otra politólogo muy
influyente como como bien decía leonardo
se movían en todo un círculo han pasado
primeros ministros les caso un primer
mini en el primer ministro varios
primeros ministros pasaban por su casa
en la casa en la que parte la casa de
verano en la que parte de los abusos
fueron cometidos y bueno así ver bernard
kouchner es uno de los de los franceses
más internacionales no es sólo un
exministro es éste no tiene una
presencia internacional en el campo
humanitario muy grande
es una familia que empezaba muchísimo
uno de los amigos y uno perdón que me
salte pero uno de los grandes escándalos
de esto es no solo no sabe silencia a la
familia que eso es algo que pasa en
todas las familias es el silencio por
eso es la familia grande el silencio de
mucha gente que conocía que había sabido
y que bueno puede como el propio
granados neón de hicieran porque la el
propio la propia víctima decía no no no
denunciarlo no dijeran nada pero
permitieron que el idiota y gmail que es
el acusado siguiera escalando posiciones
llegó a presidir el club de siècle que
es un club súper elitista de político
muy cerrado que excederá las las manijas
del poder es decir que permitieron que
alguien que sabían o que sospechaban que
tienen la conducta criminal
del abuso sexual contra un menor que es
una de las de los abusos sexuales más
graves por todo lo que implica pudiera
seguir escalando y teniendo puestos
también incluso con gente muy joven o
sea con estudiantes da una relación con
estudiantes eso es también lo que ha
causado yo creo un gran shock
a los que sabían y que permitieron que
alguien así detuviera tanta influencia
en esos años a los que se refería a
leonardo si no es sino hasta hoy mismo
increíble porque cambia
jesús y sus hermanos hablaron de eso ya
hace diez años pero esto mucha gente la
mayoría no quería escuchar eso en este
círculo donde del cual estamos hablando
porque debemos decir que normalmente
se pone el incesto relación a clases
sociales más bajas esto es un clásico lo
que la cosa que sorprende en este en
este caso es que estamos en una clase
intelectual y social alta desde diez
años se sabía a nivel yo ya me la ha
continuado a hacerla la misma vida es
una conseja va también el actual
presidente ma chrome esto es es bastante
bastante increíble creo que da ahora
debo decir que ahora hay una encuesta de
la judiciaria en francia entonces
nuestro también empezar el final de esta
encuesta pero la lo que dice camilla los
hermanos son cosas muy graves el hecho
que él o libia yo amé la continuada de
hacer una vida entre comillas normal
esta es dice que en este círculo de
personas por mucha gente el incesto o la
pedofilia puede ser una cosa normal
tremendo voy a hacer una pequeña pausa y
a la vuelta vamos a hablar de las
implicaciones políticas y también
judiciales que tiene este asunto del
incesto serían enseguida
aquí en primera plana
[Música]
en rusia las protestas por la
encarcelación de navalny han provocado
ya más de 1400 detenidos en los últimos
días familiares y amigos se han
concentrado cerca de los centros de
detención donde se encuentran estas
personas arrestadas para intentar
facilitarles comida y abrigo pero moscú
sigue resistiendo las presiones también
las de la unión europea que se ha
interesado por el estado de nabai y ha
criticado la ausencia de una
investigación pero moscú no está
dispuesta a permitir que le den sermones
desde bruselas o desde washington así lo
ha explicado el gobierno ruso en varias
ocasiones que durante las últimas horas
ha dirigido incluso mensajes muy claros
a los gobiernos occidentales diciéndoles
que es hora de que se empiecen a
preocupar por sus propios asuntos y no
insistan más sobre el caso naval ni
[Música]
desde el departamento de estado yo bailé
en dijo que alexéi navalni tiene que ser
liberado del encarcelamiento
políticamente motivado del que está
siendo víctima al presidente bailén
aseguró también que a pesar de los
esfuerzos que se están haciendo en
términos diplomáticos con moscú ve con
mucha preocupación los esfuerzos rusos
de suprimir la libertad de expresión y
de manifestarse de forma pacífica según
by the naval ni ha sido atacado por
denunciar la corrupción en rusia y
debería ser liberado inmediatamente y
sin condiciones por su parte el
secretario de estado- anthony blinken le
ha pedido también al gobierno ruso de
putin que libere inmediatamente a
navalny y a los cientos de ciudadanos
rusos que fueron detenidos ilegalmente
tras ejercer su derecho a manifestarse
[Música]
tras la condena de tres años y medio de
prisión a alexéi navalni la manuela con
reaccionó en su cuenta de twitter
diciendo que el respeto de los derechos
humanos y como de la libertad
democrática no son negociables el
mandatario ha mantenido una diálogo
estratégico con moscú y lo ha hecho
participe en la gestión de las
diferentes crisis mundiales de los
últimos años pero parece que esto no ha
dado fruto y ahora francia pues ha
decidido subir el tono de voz en contra
de moscú fue el secretario de estado de
asuntos europeos el que dijo que para
ejercer una verdadera presión sobre
moscú hay que detener el proyecto nord
stream 2 usted gasoducto que se está
construyendo entre alemania y rusia un
proyecto muy importante a nivel
económico pero sobre todo a nivel
geopolítico para moscú de hecho francia
pues ya ha hecho la petición a berlín
pero lo cierto es que angela merkel
hasta ahora ha dicho que el proyecto
continúa en pie lo que sí es seguro es
que francia va a poner sobre la mesa la
discusión de las sanciones a rusia en el
próximo consejo europeo
[Música]
sarajevo managua balín ciudades que como
tantas otras han sufrido la guerra el
hambre la dictadura o catástrofes
naturales fukushima gross y la habana
france24 vuelve a las regiones que
marcaron la actualidad internacional sus
habitantes cuentan su nueva vida sus
esperanzas y su lucha para superar un
pasado traumático
un colector de vuelta una serie inédita
de reportajes en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
seguimos aquí en primera plan esta
semana hablando del incesto con los
periodistas silvia yus o leonardo
martinelli y con la psicóloga maría
eugenia uriburu el incesto es un
problema gravísimo también en
latinoamérica el problema es que las
estadísticas son casi imposibles de
obtener varios organismos calculan que
en américa latina sólo se denuncia una
cuarta parte de violaciones sexuales que
ocurren las que menos se denuncian son
las que constituyen incesto casi
prácticamente invisibles
mariah esta multiplicación que vemos
ahora estos días en francia de denuncias
en las redes sociales es quizá no sé si
la única forma de combatirlo ahora mejor
quizás no sea la mejor es la que es la
más actual es la que la que sale la que
viene no hay manera
buena o mala de tomar la palabra cuando
se ha vivido violencia es importante
hacerlo es difícil que se escuche es
estar con tan atroz que es difícil que
se pueda escuchar entonces las víctimas
y suelen decirlo lo que pasa es que uno
no los escucha y el michu permite este
efecto expansivo como decía al principio
que éste es favorable es favorable
siempre pienso que la gente se siente
unida que esto hace despertarla
al poder político porque son cuestiones
muy graves que se naturalizan y que
lamentablemente por falta de decisión
política estos temas no avanzan desde
hace muchísimo tiempo se necesitan
medios para poder este
escuchar las víctimas formar a los
profesionales para recibir la palabra de
los chicos responsabilizar a los adultos
ya los profesionales que escuchan este
tipo de testimonio y que no tienen las
herramientas porque les da miedo porque
son familias pueden ser familias con
mucho poder que es imposible se
naturaliza y se desvaloriza la palabra
siendo que un niño no puede estar
inventando esto lo que es muy
impresionante de michu es que realmente
vemos este la magnitud son muy
emocionantes muy emotivos estos
testimonios y la gente se apoya y bueno
cada uno quizás de todas estas personas
se van a ir animando a quizás tomar una
cita con una jurista
confidencial o consultar o hablar con
las amigas o los amigos y así de a poco
cada uno puede ir armando el camino
hacia la reconstitución porque son
golpes psíquicos muy fuertes muy fuertes
muy descriptores hablemos un poco de las
herramientas legales que tenemos para
afrontar esta realidad
silvia con qué herramientas legales
afrontar esta está esa cuestión les voy
a preguntar enseguida si hay que
legislar más o si en realidad tenemos
esas herramientas ya hay herramientas
las hay desde hace tiempo
hay penas en el caso francés hay penas
para abusos sexuales contra menores para
casos de violación de un menor de 15
años hay hasta 20 años
el incesto es un agravante
ya hay penas lo que muchos expertos
dicen es si se puede se puede afinar se
puede mejorar las las leyes de hecho nos
ha y ahora todo el mundo se tira de los
pelos y están volviendo a hablar en el
parlamento de pone una ley de de poner
una edad de consentimiento mínima que en
francia sigue sin haberlo pero pareciera
es que hace dos años en 2018 con la ley
que se llama la divisa para de la
entonces ministra de igualdad marlene
siapa que era una ley contra los abusos
sexuales y sexistas sobre todo contra
las mujeres pero ya se habló de la ley
de edad de consentimiento y no se llegó
a ningún acuerdo es decir fracasó hace
sólo dos años y ahora de repente
pareciera que han descubierto casi el
agua tibia otra vez no es decir se
muestra que hay a veces es muy fácil
decir vamos a hacer más leyes o vamos a
mejorar leyes cuando ya hay leyes y lo
que muchos grupos es lo que comentaba
maría eugenia lo que muchos grupos
las feministas que las vistas en youtube
son las que las que lanzaron la campaña
del mito incesto en lo que dicen es
bueno hay leyes se puede mejorar pero
sobre todo lo importante es la formación
de profesionales no sirve de nada de
profesionales tanto los médicos los
expertos los psicólogos que reciben a un
niño que tienen que saber interpretar lo
que dice un niño porque un niño tampoco
bien dice mi papá me violó a mí que me
violó un niño hace un dibujo un niño
hace dice algún comentario que tiene que
chocar hay que saber recibirlo y también
por ejemplo los policías que es el mismo
caso que ellas citan que es lo
interesante con la violencia contra las
mujeres que muchos el gran problema de
la violencia de la evidencia contra las
mujeres que muchas mujeres no van a
denunciarlo porque llegan a comisaría y
casi se ríen de ellas no les hacen caso
les las desestiman tiene que haber
profesionales que sepan cómo actuar y
que tengan esa sensibilidad y eso es eso
requiere un entrenamiento una formación
y eso es lo que hizo más importante la
prevención que sólo penalizar también lo
que dicen si el incesto ya se pueden
endurecer las leyes pero ya hay leyes y
ya sabes que te van a pueden dar cinco
años y aún así se comete incesto
quizá el problema sobre todo más la
prevención que la
aunque haya que castigar por supuesto
que hay que castigar pero quizás lo más
urgente no es legislar más sino prevenir
mejor en el bar esas asociaciones dicen
de hecho eso que el asunto consiste en
hacer cesar esa violencia más que buzz
castigar la mejor y si hablamos de hacer
cesar esa violencia donde vamos maría
eugenia o leonardo que cuando un chico
habla con un niño abre el abre la boca
habla se lo escuche porque eso va a
cambiar todo en la historia que se lo
pueda escuchar que se le tome las tome
en serio lo que está diciendo permite a
ponerlo a la fría para protegerlo
y separarlo del agresor todo el
traumatismo en el post traumatismo lo
que es lo que se denomina también tiene
que ver con esto con que la persona
habló en algún momento no se la escuchó
y la los actos siguieron y no hubo
ningún tipo de protección entonces si
cuanto antes se pueda formar para
escuchar y por eso la voluntad política
de formar y poner dinero ahí es
importante de formar de escuchar tomarse
el tema en serio porque es tabú es
difícil habla de sexualidad habla de
niños es atroz
las las consecuencias psíquicas son
enormes
[Música]
no sé si puedo decirlo ahora pero en
todo caso las consecuencias psíquicas de
las violaciones son como en la tortura
100% de post traumatismo no hay no
lamentablemente va directo al
traumatismo que quiere decir que la
persona va a tener problemas de memoria
durante muchísimo tiempo que
esta cuestión del silencio y de la de no
poder hablar y tratar de no pensar hace
que lamentablemente el síntomas revenga
en el cuerpo que viene vuelve esto esto
sigue hablando es decir aunque el niño
no lo diga lo va a mostrar con el cuerpo
lo va a mostrar por un lado escuchar
mejor a los niños pero por otro lado
también atacar esa posición de
dominación sexual que se ejerce porque
el agresor ejerce un papel y cómo se
atacan esos cimientos del agresor sexual
esa posición de dominación es un asunto
que también está en la violencia
machista yo creo que es verdad que en
francia en la tendencia que todo se
soluciona con las leyes esto no es
posible
pero quería recordar una cosa que este
tema de la edad de con del
consentimiento es importante es un poco
extraño que la francia que tiene muchas
leyes y que ya está no la tengan lista y
no la tenga y quiero también a recordad
que ahora hay un proyecto de ley en el
parlamento el senado hace 13 años y esto
creo que ustedes debe recordar que es
una cosa una cosa importante a esta edad
y en otros países europeos y
asociaciones que consideran que es
demasiado baja poco ambiciosa en 13 años
la mayoría de los países europeos 15
maría eugenia en esto de la edad de
consentimiento esto ya lo fijamos si no
no no no soy experta como para decirlo
space verdad que las asociaciones
sostienen más bien 14 15 años los
derechos del niño de la onu dijo que 13
años será demasiado era muy joven ellos
en la unicef
en un informe no fijaron edad pero
consideraba que 13 años era muy bajo
luego también las recomendaciones una de
las recomendaciones que me pareció muy
interesante era que la edad mínima legal
para el consentimiento sexual que no sea
ni demasiado bajo pero tampoco ni
demasiado alto que es lo que pasa a
veces que se paga más lladó sobre todo
de tener contener disposiciones que
tengan en cuenta la diferencia de edad
limitada entre las parejas por ejemplo
tres años no es lo mismo que que haya
una relación o abuso en este caso entre
un adolescente de 13 14 años con digamos
su profesor o con su tío de 30 o 40 50
que una relación de un adolescente de 13
14 años con un chico que acaba de chica
que acaba de cumplir 7 18 años es decir
que esto es bueno en los motivos por los
que en francia fracasó el fija una ley
de consentimiento pero bueno ahí hay un
discernimiento y hay maneras de hay
maneras de un juez no es blanco y negro
también ven las circunstancias y yo creo
que yo estoy de acuerdo yo creo que una
edad de consentimiento es importante
para que haya un punto un punto de
anclaje a partir del cual se puedan
tomar decisiones no y quizá la gran
diferencia que existe entre esta
denuncia o esta vez con veces anteriores
sea el tratamiento mediático quizás la
diferencia de esta vez en concreto es
que se permita a las víctimas ocupar ese
espacio mediático sin ser cuestionadas
no es decir la diferencia es que en el
pasado sí que existían esas denuncias
pero se cuestionaba quizá a las víctimas
con todos los prejuicios y las excusas
de la cultura de la violación que acaban
dando a lo mejor excusas a los
violadores incluso si retomamos hacia
atrás encontramos casos como el del
gerente del fmi dominique strauss-kahn
cuando en 2011 lo primero que se hace
como tratamiento mediático es cuestionar
el testimonio de la víctima desde ahí ha
pasado muchas cosas ha pasado el mito ha
pasado del feminismo ha dado grandes
pasos y quizá ese es el gran cambio que
al que asistimos más ahora que no se
cuestionen sus tests y ganas el mito
empezó con unas actrices que denunciaban
y una vela
a la cara visible es harvey weinstein
anteriormente todo poderoso productor de
cine que está ahora en la cárcel es
decir siempre pues bueno por desgracia
son voces son las voces por eso es
importante que futbolistas famosos
denunciar el racismo denuncian abusos
etcétera porque son son los que los que
se escucha por motivos correctos e
incorrectos son los que tienen una se
les escucha y tiene una palabra que a
otros se les niega o se ignora pues es
lo que decías no es lo mismo que una por
desgracia que una señora de la limpieza
de un hotel e denunció una agresión
sexual a que la denuncie la hija de una
señora que es jurista que viene de una
familia intelectual muy grande y muy
importante y que provoca vergüenza e
incluso a nivel nacional no es un
embarazo nacionales etc en brazos por
cierto que el año pasado fue el libro de
banes spring ahora que antes nombra a mi
compañera silvia quien causó otra chispa
para un debate social sobre abusos ahora
es otro libro esta es una particularidad
francese a lo de los libros y al igual
que en otros países son las actrices o
en otros pero aquí en francia lo vemos
mucho a golpe del libro no y son libros
bien
escritos también en el libro de galicia
spring ahora ha tenido un éxito
increíble y también los críticos
literarios son muy muy positivos en un
libro que se lee que se lee muy bien yo
creo que como decía antes la novedad es
el tipo de persona también que hace que
critique que hace este tipo de testigo
humanista spring ahora también venía de
una familia intelectual esa clase social
alta los padres esto ya lo cuenta en el
libro aceptaban la relación con gabriel
masner porque gabriel basáñez era un
escritor muy conocido esto hace
hasta hace un año y creo que uno no
puede decir nada contra este tipo de
persona que vinculará es un abogado
entonces esto creo que hasta la gran
novedad de este fenómeno ahora en
francia me quedo sin tipo para más un
placer silvia leonardo maria eugenia
muchas gracias por haberme acompañado
este en primera plana sobre el incesto y
nosotros nos vemos la próxima semana
quienes recibirán 24 gracias